stability is the key word in this
election that is what new democracy
leader kiriakos mitsotakis says he seeks
and why he didn't try to form a
government after claiming 41 of the
first vote a month ago
the voice of Athens resounds across
Greece tonight that it also ReSound at
The Ballot Box on Sunday only then will
we end this two-month election marathon
with a result that will give the country
a stable government a new democracy
government a result that will give us
the strength to implement our plan for
our Southern Greece
problem in May was the electoral system
voted in by the previous left-wing
syriza government
one of proportional representation
parties divide up the chamber's 300
seats in proportion to their share of
the vote new democracy has brought back
Greece's predominant system known as
enhanced proportionality in May
mitsataki's got just 145 seats shy of
the 151 he needed to govern on his own
if enhanced proportionality had been in
place he would have got 170 seats so he
held out for another election when
enhanced proportionality will apply many
people seem to agree with him I think it
was right I think that he wanted to have
a majority so that he would be able to
govern without having to do a coalition
government from what I have observed and
what I've read about he wanted to have
stability in the government and
particularly I think now with many
different international events going on
I think having stability might actually
make sense
proportional representation was wrong
and the parties that voted for it to
have admitted that it's tiring the
people out and I don't think Greece is
ready for it it may never be and it's
expensive elections cost 300 million
euros but there may also be a historical
reason for mitsataki's decision his
father prime minister Constantine
mitsutagi's fought proportional
representation through three election
rounds to form a government without
Coalition Partners
when people want to vote for something
they'll vote for It Whatever the system
look at mitsotaki's father during the
1989 to 1990 elections he also had to
deal with proportional representation
and ended up getting 47 percent it's
very difficult for an electoral system
to stop the will of the people it
appears the younger mitsotakis doesn't
want to take 18 months to rule on his
own by comparison two months is
relatively quick John saropoulos Al
Jazeera Athens foreign